um it's december the 17th
2020 and uh i never thought that i would
be here
at this place at this time in my life it
was kind of rough there for a moment
we're longer than a moment and um i'd
like to start off this
this topic as um or something that
that happened to me last night um
i got off of work last night and i paid
my mom a visit
because it's been about three months
since i last seen her
but i talked to her almost every day and
while i was in there and when i first
got there you know i couldn't even hug
her man
because of you know her age her
condition you know the things she's
going through she's working with she got
some
health issues and she's 70 74
70 i think 76 years old you know
and um i wanted to greet her with the
kiss on the on the forehead
here here here and on the lips you know
because that's how i greeted her when i
first came home from prison
and um i got that concept from a book i
was reading
and um the book was um
the writer of the book said her son had
a best friend
whose father was an alcoholic who lost
his mom when he was like four years old
and his father was mean to him and she
knew his father
didn't was mistreating him not in a ways
of
physical abuse but verbally wasn't there
for him because he was always drunk
so every time her son bring his friend
his best friend over to the house
she would greet him with the kiss on her
forehead the two
left side cheeks and on the lips and
said i love you
and when i read that i cried and
i experienced that in prison that was
like two and a half years before parole
i read that that paragraph in that book
and two and a half years later when i
was released for [ __ ] prison
first place i went to was my mom's place
i kissed her on her forehead
put her cheeks and on her lips and i
said i love you
she said you never did that before
where'd this come from
i said from some a book that i read
it it meant something to me and that
would mean some to her
and it all came back full circle last
night when i went to her house and i
couldn't greet her
in that way to show her
um her birthday was september
and i had missed it because i didn't
have the money
so what happened was when i got to her
place last night i said look mama i have
to run to the store
to get a few things i'll be right back i
went to the uh
the ralph supermarket took me about
45 minutes to find the right card
but i found it and i presented it to her
and she read it
said put your mask on i put my mask on
just hug me and help me
and um that's how i left her house man
you know
he said i love you and words can
describe what it feels like
just to get that that feeling you know
because today
i i'm not on time for people birthdays
and
and christmases and holidays and [ __ ]
like that sometimes they're young but
it's like hit and miss with me
because i have two left feet you know
i'm sorry i'm not like the little train
i could
i i want to think i have you know life
is good and i got my [ __ ] together
but in all honesty i don't man it's
trial and error even dealing with my
family
it's hit and miss because all the times
that i was in prison all the time
all the rehabs all the trips of the
[ __ ]
you know just having further and further
away from from dealing with my
my loved ones crack to everything
i gave craig everything that i had my
mind
my body damn that my soul family
[ __ ] put them in the pipe and smoke them
relationships
i don't give a [ __ ] jump never
jobs man it's [ __ ] you can't pay me the
word
be are you are you serious
and um last night you showed me
that there's a lot of work ahead for me
you know there's a lot of work ahead for
me man
and um i like to start off with hey
[ __ ] man i've been working now for about
three months
and i work in the construction field
but my thing is under the table you know
and why under the table because that's
where that's what it turned out for me
i've um i was in the gym man for about
how long have i been home i've been home
from prison
may may of 2017 and i was in the gym
every day from eighth out from may 2017
up until
about eight months ago before the covet
hit corporate 19
and um they shut it down and
the first time they shut it down man i
was depressed for about
seven days i had withdrawals like i had
flu symptoms
and um i didn't eat i didn't sleep i
didn't drink water and nothing
for about four days and then three days
after that still depressed
it took me about a week and a half to
to to get through it and then they
opened back up the gems and i was like
hippie parade and um
i went for the for the next two weeks
and they shut it down again
and um i remember being in my my room
and i was in bed and i was just thinking
to myself
if something doesn't happen
then my body of spirit i i just saw
myself sinking and quick sin
i just saw myself just sinking and
sinking without nobody being able to
help the
the lend a hand down to give me about
that and um
that's what it felt like man i said i
can't go through
what i went through the first time they
shut it down
not eating sleeping and being depressed
man it
[ __ ] me up
why the gym is my foundation i've been
dealing with the gm now for the past
30 years the gym helped me through my
20s it helped me through my 30s it
helped me through my 40s
that's all i had was my body
my looks to get me through and it worked
for his relationships with women you
know women were attracted to the body
the size the look and that's what
carried me man
you know it didn't help me stay out of
prison
it didn't help me stay out of
[ __ ] rehabs it didn't help me
keep from being homeless over and over
and over again
better work with the women with the
ladies
you know only work for so long because
soon as the cracks start knocking on the
door there i go
and eventually i put her in the pipe and
smoke her up too with the furniture
and everything else that comes with it
the house the core all that [ __ ]
you know because after i take a hit
everything is a crack coupon man it's
just a coupon
matter of time going on a business cell
you know and that's just the way it was
and um so i'm in my room
and i'm thinking to myself i can't go
through what i went through the first
time
and creator you have to show me
something please
the next day i got a phone call from an
old friend of mine he said hey would you
like to work
this happened to be the weekend i said
sure
he came to my house and got me and i've
been working ever since
it's going on four months i learned how
to paint
i learned how to lay cement and now i'm
refurbishing floors wood floors
and um i work seven days a week
or six days a week now hit and miss it
all depends
now truth be told i'm not getting paid
what i'm supposed to be paid
because like i said i'm not certified
qualified and none of that [ __ ]
but where i get paid is in the
experience
being taught something that i've never
been taught before
everything i'm learning in my 50s
i should have had that [ __ ] in my 20s
30s and 40s but see how i had to twist
it
i had to jam in my 20 30s and 40s and
the only thing that worked was the
outside
sort of give me that feeling that i
needed on the inside
because what i got from the inside was
everybody's approval everybody's
accolades or the double takes and all
that [ __ ] when i'm walking down the
street
oh big man hey this step that's what
kept me going that's what kept me
motivated that's what kept my ass in the
gym
everybody else's approval how they
looked at me
flip side of the coin is when i do
a good job on the floor and i see my
work and my boss come behind me say hey
man that's a good job
you did good today man i'm proud of you
as soon as i get my [ __ ] ass
back home i
i cry like a baby
i cry you know why because every time
i think about it it takes me back to
when i was 14
15 16 years old
and all the and where i was at the time
of my life so
emotionally i feel
i get that feeling of being 15 years old
or 16
when my boss said hey man you did a good
job or when
when something when the light goes on my
mind and i said
oh i got it then the feeling comes up
but not as a 53 years old
but as a 15 year old emotionally
you know that [ __ ] is crazy i still
don't understand it
i still don't get it you know
it's a lot i don't get there's a lot
that i missed but it's okay
it's okay [ __ ] there's some questions
that i might have that i might not
never get answered to but i'm okay with
that
i'm cool with that [ __ ]
aside from working um
i'm i'm i'm just at a place man where
i'm learning how to deal with me
be good to me treat myself take care of
me and everything else that comes with
it
you know it's not easy me
being on my own in my own place being
responsible for me taking responsibility
and all that because aside from me
there's other people
that i have to deal with and interact
with you know in
in in in that that that bridge man
that's it's a long bridge that i have to
cross man
just to just to be like that with my
immediate family
um my brother's starting to come around
slowly but surely
he might have saw one of the segments
but he asked me some questions and um he
came by the job site
and um he said hey you know um there's
some things you didn't know about me but
my hobbies are this and this now look
i said okay i had no idea i'm like man i
appreciate you sharing that with me
so that let me know and let me know
something that he's putting forth an
effort
you know i'm not looking for i'm not
looking for no
no um
what does i'm not looking for um
no apologies no nothing like that meant
for the past man it is what the [ __ ] it
is man
you know we've had our experiences we do
as is growing up
we never been close we never had no
relationship we've never had no close
bond
you know um i told him man i said you
know what
you're you're a stranger to me you're a
brother
and just in wording insane i said i
don't know
anything pertinent about you i don't
know nothing important about you i don't
know your favorite color
i don't know your favorite foods i don't
know your hobbies
none of that you know that's it man we
never did one thing together growing up
we never went to the football game
together we never played ball together
we never went to the movies together
nothing
one-on-one i said we have to start off
with strangers
work at being friends and maybe one day
we can become brothers
because if we don't start a stranger's
man
then there will always be a
misunderstanding there'll always be
confusion
you know it'll be like it was man back
in the days you know always bumping
heads
because you're talking about you oh
you're my little brother and all that
i'm your you're my big brother but in
actuality
man i've been gone 20 some years off and
on since the 80s
all them 20-something trips 19 trips to
prison
you know this two years three years four
years nine where they did all that
[ __ ]
there's a lot we missed out on so me
coming out
and and and uh coming out of 2017 i've
been gone since 2011.
you want to pick up where we left off
[ __ ]
man we got to start when we was kids
because there's a lot missing right
there
it ain't great it ain't no gray area
[ __ ] it's a black area it's black and
white ain't no grain
between it's black white and then the
gray
black is just total absence
no communication no nothing for
different points of time
different periods of time so
every time i'm around him i feel like a
stranger
the only one i'm close to is my mother
why
because she wrote me all the trips all
the 19 trips to prison
she wrote me and stayed in contact with
me that's how i was able to build that
relationship with her
and stay like that with her those 19
[ __ ] trips
but she filled me in on how my family my
siblings was doing
oh tracy's doing this todd's doing this
chris is doing that
isaiah so
i'm looking at them through her eyes
through her experience but i have to
have my own experience with them
to get the full picture
keep walking nobody else's shoes or
nobody else's experience
it can guide me i got to i got to work
on my own shoes have my own experiences
with isaiah christopher todd tracy
i've been home i've been on what 17 3
years
and i'm now closer to to building a
relationship with none of them except my
mama i'm
working on it but i'm a work in progress
man and the cool thing about is
everybody have [ __ ] life
everybody's doing their thing you know
everybody's dealing with something
but everybody's above water so i'm cool
with that
i'm cool with that you know it's going
to take some time
time might not be on my side it might i
don't know [ __ ]
i'm not a fortune teller but um
family um it's a mystery
job i'm learning you know
but one thing about work is i like
working
i like hard work you know [ __ ]
and sundays i do i do see i do uh
concrete
um uh uh c maintenance woman's um
uh yard she wants to make it to a uh uh
a parking
a parking lot so she can excuse me a
parking area so her kids or two sons can
park their vehicles on the property
instead of on the streets because it's
good kind of crowded
and um man doing an eight hour
day i'm i might lift about
75 80 60 pound bags of c men
take them to the designated area where
the mixer is open them up and pour them
into the mixer
man by the time i'm finished i feel like
i'd have worked out in the gym at like
three hours
so in essences seven days a week six
days a week i'm i'm i'm
i'm i'm i'm in a gym but it's it's a
different workout it's a different way
and i feel it in the diff i feel in
different areas
you know i feel i don't feel in my chest
my arms my shoulders my back my legs
but i do but it's just it's a different
feeling
and most importantly this kind of
workout
it helps me from the inside out it's
just my inner
is that that self-esteem that's
self-worth
you know it it gives me it gives me uh
it builds character
[ __ ] you know and
what i'm being taught nobody can take
away from me
and everything i'm being taught is the
right way how to do some [ __ ]
i know the right way how to lace c man i
know the right way how to paint
i know the right way how to do a floor
so my my my teachers the men
that are in my life the three men that
i'm dealing with
they're giving me the right information
the right tools
to succeed in these three areas which
enables me to succeed in life
now i have to work on dealing with my
family in that area because it hasn't
transformed
i haven't it haven't been manifested in
that area yet
you know but long if if i could just
stay on the street nero
and get these experiences from these
different jobs that i'm doing
and and learn them then it'll roll over
into different areas you know
i think i it took me three days
to learn how to paint real good i mean
for real for real
took me three days took me about two
weeks how to do the cement
and about one week how to work
how to work the floor you know and um
i wish it was like that with my family i
wish it was like that and
with life you know but it's not man it's
not
i still have two left feet it's easy for
my ass to trip
i have to be careful always you know
there's not a date that i can let
up there's no there's not a there's not
a day man
that i can just um
wake up in the morning and think to
myself or today i'm just gonna [ __ ]
laying around to do nothing
you know i'm not gonna pray i'm not
gonna meditate i'm not you know i'm not
gonna
i'm just gonna just say effort you know
you know and when i think about those
days on the right right ended up
in prison in the crack house
on the side of a [ __ ] freeway
off ramp and i don't want that today
i want something more than that i
deserve more than that i owe myself more
than that
you know [ __ ] life is scary
you know because i'm i've escaped i've
been running for so long
ran over 30 years and all of a sudden i
got almost three years
of dealing with some [ __ ] and at the
time i didn't want to deal with it
up until they shut down the gems
then my foundation was crushed because
that was my foundation
the gym my body how i look
that's all i had so i had to offer to
the world as i know it
but lo and behold there was more to me
than
than i even knew i didn't believe enough
i couldn't even see it what i see
now but the cool thing about is instead
of seeing some [ __ ] i'm living some [ __ ]
that's the difference i'm living it
living my [ __ ] dream what's
that doing the things i never thought
i'd do
doing the [ __ ] i was supposed to do in
my 20s 30s and 40s doing that [ __ ] in
50s
that's one of those unspoken prayers is
being nasty
[ __ ]
it ain't easy
but it's okay it's okay
never thought i'd be here never thought
i'd be in this position this place
mind body and spirit well i wake up in
the morning and the first thing i think
about
is being on time
i'm going to how i'm going to do today
what i'm going to do
you know and when i get there you know
put forth the effort man do the best
that i can do throughout the day man
and that's it and when i'm coming back
you know the cool thing about it is when
i leave
instead of getting picked up by my boss
i catch the bus and train to the job
site
just so i have time just to relax and
get my mind together to
deal with whatever they has in store you
know and same when i get finished with
work
i have my boss take me to the to the
train station or the bus station
i get mass on there so i have time just
to unwind
from what i experienced and just let it
let it marinate
you know and um by the time i get home
i'm good you know i'm with me
it ain't about that it ain't about the
double takes with [ __ ] like it
ain't about that no more
i don't even trip on that i'm not even i
haven't been in a relationship in about
nine months i'm not on the bus and
trains looking at them peeping and
trying to get out the women
i admire them i love them i love them
all i love women
[ __ ] i ain't tripping on that but the
point is i'm not out there trying to
trying to get in no relationship or
nothing like that man i'm just out
and dealing with life and joining for
what it is man you know
and um when it's the right time god's
going god's gonna
put her in my life i'm not worried about
that you know but my thing is everything
that i thought would make me happy
you know it was all from the outside you
know but what really makes me happy
is um
having the courage to get up and face
another day
come with me
[Music]
that's it man in a nutshell there's so
much i want
but what i really need is to keep doing
what the [ __ ] i'm doing stand in my lane
and out the way
[ __ ] i want everything
i want it all
but um i'm only giving what what i need
just to make it through the day
you know and um that's enough for me man
you know that's enough of me there's so
much more that i can talk about
when it comes to to to being home
being free and trying to navigate
life on life terms not on my terms
if it was on my terms i'd have a car i
have a two bedroom apartment
i'd be in a relationship have kids
motorboat mobile home you have to have
the
merry-go-round in the back of the yard
and all that [ __ ] you know
10 kids running around
you know but um in reality
all i got is me
i have to depend on me love on me and
treatment all that [ __ ] man
and sometimes it you know it
it's scary to be honest with you
it's it's it's it's just because i'm by
myself i'm alone and i have to do this
i have some assistance i get i get
suggestions
and stuff like that but when it's all
said and done i have to put one foot in
front of the [ __ ] mother i'm
gonna [ __ ] to somebody take me by the
hand and just guide me
i still got to do it i still got to do
my part
and that's that's what's scary but it's
it's
um but it it's scary but at the same
time
it gives me the freedom to go where i've
never gone before to be who i never
thought i'd become
i wouldn't trade it for nothing else
and um like i said there's so much more
i can talk about man but
the bottom line is um
i only get one i only get one chance at
this
and um
it's about time that i showed up
you know and um
i'm just glad man that had the
opportunity
to uh put my money where my mouth is
so um today i'll let my actions speak
louder than my words
i'll talk a good one but i can show you
some [ __ ] i learned today
and my work is good yeah bet your last
dolly
take that [ __ ] check to the
bank and cash it i got something to
offer today
and it ain't my body it ain't my lucks
i got some real skills to pay the bills
holla
thank you
you